when President Trump arrived here at
Miami's Federal Courthouse he
surrendered himself for arrest and was
formally booked along with his aide Walt
router the hearing itself lasted just
under an hour and was presited over by
the duty magistrate Jonathan Goodman the
former president sat stone-faced first
with his hands clasped in front of him
and then as the hearing proceeded he
crossed his arms none of it was on
camera Mr Trump's lawyer then entered a
plea on the former president's behalf we
most certainly enter a plea of not
guilty the lawyer said the prosecution
did not request that Mr Trump's passport
be handed over and there were no
International or domestic travel
restrictions placed on him what's known
as a personal surety bond was requested
with no Financial component bail
essentially with no requirement to hand
over money
it's all about classified documents
found at Mr Trump's Mar-A-Lago Resort
documents that he should have handed
over to the National Archive when he
lost the presidency the National Archive
realized that some were missing and
asked Trump's team for them back some
were handed over but some remained
missing and in August last year the FBI
raided his home more documents were
found 67 were marked as confidential 92
a secret and 25 as top secret according
to the indictment they included
information regarding defense and
weapons capabilities of both the U.S and
other countries as well as the United
States nuclear program and the weakness
of the National Defense of other nations
a grand jury of ordinary Americans then
concluded that the evidence against Mr
Trump was enough to pursue a prosecution
but why did Mr Trump have these
documents what was the intention of
taking them we do not know
Mr Trump has denied any wrongdoing he
claims that he was able to declassify
the documents
Mr Trump boy win holding nuclear secrets
sir hey
foreign
well in social media posts on his way to
court Mr Trump repeated the claim that
all this is a politically motivated
Witch Hunt and on his behalf outside
Court his lawyer said the decision to
pursue the charges against him while
turning a blind eye to others is
emblematic of the corruption we have
here she said we are at a turning point
in our nation's history
she's referencing the case of the
documents found at President Biden's
home and in an office he once used these
cases are also under investigation and
President Biden has not been accused of
obstructing justice or trying to hide
any documents as president Trump is
alleged to have done
well there will be legal arguments Mr
Trump's defense team will try to have
the case thrown out they will argue that
some of the evidence is inadmissible in
court they will try to delay the trial
potentially Beyond next year's November
presidential election and honestly it is
impossible to know quite how all this
will play out either legally or
politically or frankly in society Mr
Trump commands a large following in
America remember well over 70 million
people voted for him in 2020. how many
of them remain loyal and what about
Republican politicians what will they do
we just don't know but it is clear that
in communities across the country Mr
Trump's message does resonate
[Applause]